المكسرات من جميع الأصناف هي مصادر جيدة
للألياف الدهنية
والبروتينات فقط تأكد من أن أي شخص
يتعامل معها أو يأكلها ليس لديه
حساسية من الجوز.
الفول السوداني
هو النوع غير المشبع الصحي
الذي يقلل من مخاطر الإصابة بأمراض القلب
والسكتة الدماغية ،
والآن يعتبر اللوز أحد أفضل
مصادر فيتامين (هـ) الذي قد يساعد في منع
أو تأخير أمراض القلب والتدهور المعرفي
، كما أن اللوز غني
بالمغنيسيوم مما يساعد على تنظيم نسبة السكر في الدم.
يوفر الجوز فقط المزيد
من مضادات الأكسدة أكثر من أي نوع آخر من
المكسرات ، لكن الدراسات تشير إلى أن الجوز قد يساعد في
تقليل
الالتهاب كعامل في العديد من
الأمراض
المزمنة.الكاجو يوفر المغذيات
المغنيسيوم والمنغنيز للمساعدة في
الحفاظ على صحة العظام والفستق
مصدر رائع لفيتامين B6
ويمكن أن يساعد أيضًا في دعم
مستويات الكوليسترول الصحية